[Música]
mesmo nos perguntar o simples que
garante
eu não tenho aqui traz nas costas uma
pistola 9 milímetros por exemplo e
começa a disparar sobre a origem a
partida no um check point não foi
revistado
não houve nenhuma tensão tais tanto o
que os grandes
eu não tenho isso nada e ainda assim
permanecem sentados
convém resta tóquio não vai ser
necessariamente inspiracional
motivacional essa desculpa por isso
podemos um outro cenário
imaginemos agora que evidenciava uma
determinada etnia por exemplo
visualmente manifestava uma determinada
religiosidade por exemplo muçulmana
através das minhas vestes procurou na
mão por exemplo e fazia a mesma pronta
garante que neste momento não tem uma
pistola 9 milímetros atrás das costas e
começa a tirar nada e ainda assim nós
com certeza permaneceriam nos lugares
como a diferença entre a primeira
realidade e sonda o melhor nesta segunda
realidade tem quase a certeza do sucesso
resposta a esta questão
você se teriam dois ou três pontos e que
está o problema de dois ou três segundos
de hesitação são claramente uma vitória
do turismo de uma trilha de lista
vamos tentar agora perceber duas casas
ou seja duas questões por que vocês
permaneceram no lugar
a primeira questão de sonda que vocês
existiriam se o tupi que o cio
aparecesse como terminaria como
terminada hoje à hora o que nos leva a
permanecer um lugar para testá lo um
princípio muito simples muito complexa
explicaram a confiança permanece nesse
lugar
não obstante não ter vivo está
checkpoint estado encontrou os processos
de confiança que isso confiança
confiança é como disse é complexa
explicar mas a confiança é podemos virar
e tecnologia vai do team confiar é quer
dizer acreditar e agir com crença tem no
seu último boletim a expressão fi 10
quer dizer fé base do sucesso da relação
de confiança que está
fé fé não necessariamente religiosa
viajamos por aqui parte dimensão
religiosa e pensar a fé acontecendo a
fórmula mais saudável loucura ou seja
estamos acreditar em qualquer coisa que
à partida não sei vivem ou seja
considerando um facto que não é
necessariamente provável
e é precisamente a relação de confiança
que nos leva a que nós somos atores
individuais sozinhos temos sempre
sozinho mas ultrapassar essa nossa
solidão isto é de um poeta chamado o
drinque dizia isso a band online mas
estou sozinho tudo faz parte da própria
condição humana essa solidão nem simples
razão de que eu nunca saberá quem é
conceição nem vocês saberão quem é que o
sul e no processo de remoção individual
nós nunca sabemos verdadeiramente que
somos
ora essa própria condição é ultrapassado
por um processo de renovação de fé ou
seja eu vou querer a partida que tu não
vais querer mal de mim nem vou querer
marketing e que temos então por sua
exposição de confiança que é uma base
fundamental para o processo de interação
social
nós vimos a confiança é baseada na fé
logo é baseada em nada nesse sentido mas
permaneceram porque efetivamente
acabaram por confiar
agora nós temos que pensar que confiança
é baixo como eu disse do processo de
integração social
saltamos diretamente à política e
pensamos que quanto mais confiante por
uma sociedade o quanto mais confiança
houver uma sociedade mais aberta será a
própria sociedade para ajudar esse
processo a dois vetores fundamentais
porque confiança é total fé não existe
só possível de coisas que o burrão
processo de doação de fé e aqui dois
vetores fundamentais para empurrar essa
fé
o primeiro será naturalmente o princípio
do bom na cidade
a palavra fé para ajudar a confiança um
processo de bom na vida de boa fé
isto é partiram do princípio que eu sou
uma pessoa de boa fé não ficar mal sou
um meio confiável e
não vou utilizar a violência é um
elemento fundamental do processo mas a
oficial
depois há outro elemento fundamental têm
a ver com a dissuasão pela punição que
quer dizer ou seja partiram do princípio
kill sendo um ator racional e consciente
não forem mal pela simples razão de que
se o fizer os tentar fazer o sai comigo
punido neste caso é ter um estatuto
evento que o estado é caracterizado como
sendo um legítimo monopolizador de
violência que utilizará precisamente
essa violência para evitar que haja
violência nos momentos governados por
ele próprio estado ou seja para garantir
a confiança é total fé tal salto de fé
há dois momentos fundamentais o
princípio de bonna filhas
estou princípio de boa-fé e outro é
dissuasão é puro punição
ora se nós pensarmos e voltamos a
hesitação
a exibição acontece precisamente porque
esses dois vetores não está
necessariamente impostos porque esses
dois vetores não respondem
necessariamente é como determinada
realidade que infelizmente nos ipods ou
seja hesitaram porque a partida
apresentando uma determinada etnia uma
determinada região a uma determinada
entidade partiram do princípio que essa
mesma identidade nome identidade boa fé
e portanto os dois ou três segundos de
hesitação consideram a possibilidade de
fazer mal e consideram a possibilidade
de usar a violência para tal e por outro
lado também evitaram por é tal de
dissuasão pela tal portal dissuasão pela
punição não existe ou seja 20 o estado
em si não conseguem tiros um princípio
básico é o princípio de segurança não
consegue utilizar a violência ainda que
impotência para erradicar a própria
violência é uma característica
fundamental da sua lista
ou seja os estilistas sabem a partida e
sabem de uma forma muito concreta que a
confiança é vasos tiradas abertas
isto é nossa grande fortaleza enquanto
chove
o tempo é nosso na nossa maior
vulnerabilidade porque sentem quase nada
e percebendo a partir do com frágil essa
mesma vulnerabilidade
o que o turista procura fazer é través
de discriminação a vitória de violência
e quebrar essas mesmas funções de
confiança corroer a relação de confiança
é através da disseminação do medo de uma
forma de disseminar o medo de fracassar
através do uso da violência não
necessariamente controlada pelo próprio
estado ou seja obrigar manucho pelo medo
vai trazer claramente pois com esses
gravíssimas em nível político e social
para a europa e volto a dizer hoje
dispensado foi talento e sabendo também
que está em 4 grandes estratégias a
aplicar para que esta situação se
verifica ou seja há quatro grandes
motivações estratégicas dos juristas
para aplicar para que isto aconteça
a primeira é efetivamente a punição
um jurista procura punir os eventos
procura punir com o europeu porque em
primeiro porque há valores completamente
antagônicos aos que defendem por outro
também porque são precisamente os
ocidentais e europeus que estão a
associar a sua capacidade profissional
exerce a sua capacidade de resistir ao
mesmo tempo apoiando várias entidades
que pedem também a sua própria
existência ou seja a impossibilidade de
errado e existir um défice de
perspectiva do jurista a ocidental e
portanto há uma necessidade do controle
social dessa cidade de pune a outra
questão que tem a ver com a necessidade
desestabilizado
essa determinação é fundamental porque
essa digitalização vai quebrar a tal
assunto confiança ea melhor forma de
estabilizar volto a dizer através da
disseminação da violência vil iss que é
altamente eficaz e assumir forma de ação
turista em particular pela
imprevisibilidade da ação pela
incapacidade de mitigação nessa mesma
ameaça e terceiro e mais importante pela
atualizado ou preta a diretoria da ação
o lucro fácil e imediatamente pensar
caramba
e se isso eu vai claramente é fruto do
medo volto a dizer vai quebrar é tal e
tal relação de confiança e possivelmente
pode chan
gilad os juristas aposta essencialmente
é no turismo mas é em dentro do turismo
há pelo menos quatro táticas para os
utilizados pelos combatentes
estrangeiros dos lobos solitários são
difícil verificação é do chamado
software ag isto é algo que à partida é
elevam que haja muita circulação de
pessoas e não escutarem muito reduzido e
por outro através de uma propaganda
bárbara e violenta própria a qual nós
felizmente já não estamos preparados e
que nos impressiona
ou seja é de estabilização pela
violência pelo terrorismo e pela
propaganda dados uma consciência enorme
da nossa vulnerabilidade e fui com um
conjunto de competências tecnológicas
globalização situações sociais e
políticas
hoje 2017 é consciência da nossa unidade
é muito maior do que por exemplo seria
30 40 e 50 anos atrás e sabendo mesmo
essa questão
basta por exemplo uma faca um carro de
um indivíduo como aconteceu algumas
semanas em uma missa para criar mas sim
de desculpas oficial e o máximo de
desestabilização capitulando primeiro
objetivo estratégico inicial segundo
objetivo estratégico de estabilização
para chegar ao terceiro
e esse pássaro tem a ver com aquilo que
eu falei no início ou seja purificação
das tiradas lindo doce estabilizando
vamos priorizar retirado ou seja
encontramos no principal responsável
pela violência e pela propagação do medo
uma determinada identidade uma
determinada cultura em uma determinada
região ou seja entramos no processo do
modo escritório isto é a uma determinada
entidade que aparentemente é responsável
por aquilo que efetivamente está a
acontecer e que a uma imediata punição
dos tirar essa polarização vai criar o
que há sentimento associado ao
sentimento vai ver o que a radicalização
associada à radicalização vai ver o que
é violência
isso criava a consentimento à
radicalização e à violência há mais
proximidade para o elenco
evitando polemizar a sociedade sociedade
de confiança sociedade que se vão chamar
sociedade que já não são abertas ou seja
o outro totalmente diferente
efetivamente em
fico aqui o que o preocupa e portanto
temos a punição
temos é a digitalização e temos
autorização por chegar o quarto ano do
g1
e este é o quarto grande objetivo em
relaã ã o da vitória deles ou seja a
alteração de dinâmicas poder político
que esta alteração da dinâmica de poder
político é no fundo é
institucionalização nessa mesma
polarização ou seja nós pelo medo
condicionado pelo medo
olhamos para o estadual para o poder
político e vemos uma incapacidade
reativo por parte do poder político para
mitigar esta ameaça e poder garantir
como tora fazia a abertura dos filiados
ou seja os jogos do caso específico da
europa nos últimos 30 anos desde o final
da segunda guerra mundial europa você
foi governada centro-esquerda e
centro-direita ou seja pelo bom senso
político
esse bom senso incapaz de erradicar essa
mesma ameaça está a apertar
progressivamente e portanto crescem são
os três políticos e esses próprios
termos políticos vêm com respostas
pensadas e duras para garantir
aparentemente é essa mesma segurança e
institucionalizar institucionalizar essa
mesma coisa ela tem uma consequência
pesada do próprio mesmo e nós estamos a
ver que estão a haver alterações é do
próprio panorama político a nível
pessoal holanda junto pessoas no reino
unido o brasil não deixa de ser uma
resposta pelo menos no caso da online
brasil no caso da frança vaga no caso
dos estados unidos e portanto esta
dinâmica da alteração dos poderes
políticos são institucional de sessões
da polarização e suas respostas ao medo
isso efetivamente é uma vitória de vista
quais as consequências da enchente desta
alteração da dinâmica futura política
fechamento da sociedade fechamentos
países tensão confrontos e europa
conforme nós anunciamos possivelmente
poderá vir a deixar este importante a
elas 1
o mesmo está progressivamente a
condicionar o mesmo parece ser cada vez
mais uma nova normalidade nova
normalidade essa que infelizmente pelo
cansaço está a vencer liberdade
é importante nós combatemos isso
combatemos através do que manteremos
vigilantes naturalmente não sucumbir ao
mesmo não ver a realidade de uma forma
fragmentada e não tomaram todo pela
parte sul pela volta a dizer das nossas
liberdades gerenciadas e dos nossos
filhos shalon você não há nenhum poema
fantástico é um planos pouco original
sobre o mesmo em que o mesmo vai ter
todos e tenho mesmo do que o mesmo vai
ter que é precisamente aquilo de errado
e procura disseminar o mesmo nos tirado
condicionados pelo menos fechar as
nossas cidades através da diminuição da
violência tabus nós evitar isso tanto
vigilantes e essencialmente não tomar o
topo pela parte e tentar ver a realidade
na forma na ferramenta
[Aplausos]